he likes to call himself the MVP of the
Navy I just call him the US Secretary of
the Navy
he's Ray Mabus the 75th United States
Secretary of the Navy and the longest to
serve as the leader of the Navy and
Marine Corps since World War one yeah we
had a faux pas earlier we said that
you'd be using the latrine we our
bathroom is under construction and then
we had some Naval Academy folks who said
it's a head head right what would you
think of our bathroom by the way oh it's
great it needs work yeah it does yeah
yeah yeah you picked the wrong time to
come here we picked the wrong time to
renovate our bathroom let's put it that
way yeah but the rest of the place you
like the mancave rest of the place is
pretty cool do you have a man cave I do
what's in your man cave Oh big TV and
lots of bladed weapons so you got a
bunch of swords so we're knives stuff
like that
got any sports memorabilia there oh yeah
I got lots of sports memorabilia like
what what would surprise me there I'm
not sure it would surprise you but I've
thrown out a first pitch in all 30
stadiums I got the first pitch balls no
kidding all 30 I'm the only person on
earth that's done that wow I'm impressed
by that well how are your pitches I
didn't I haven't seen the pitches though
straight right over the players they
were yeah and nobody's gonna call a ball
on you I mean you're the secretary of
the Navy
oh that was great great pitch there
secretary yeah I've learned three things
throw it out the first page okay don't
go up on the mound yes throw high yeah
arm I didn't go to overthrow anybody no
and nobody comes to see the first pitch
I still go back to when I think of Navy
football you can't help but think of
Roger Staubach right the importance of
Staubach to naval the Navy football team
was what can you put it into words oh
it's huge and you know the jerseys that
they sell at the midshipman store yeah
I'll have his number on them still you
know almost 50 years yeah after he was a
player and he comes to Navy all the time
he's he's at every army Navy
that I've been to but just the the fact
you've got a Heisman Trophy winner the
fact that you know they went to they
went to one of the big bowl games his
senior year and and he wasn't the only
Heisman Trophy winner in that period of
time I mean Joe Bellino what was their -
but Staubach and his continuing ties to
Navy his the fact that he went on active
duty because he didn't get to the NFL
til he's around 28 I think right he
spent four or five years and active duty
during Vietnam and and then went and won
a Super Bowl or several Super Bowls with
the Cowboys and and made the Pro
Football Hall of Fame that's pretty good
man you've got you've got him in
football you got David Robertson
basketball so maybe he's got a pretty
good pretty rich history in in all these
points trying to accommodate the
athletes and understand what their role
they're going to the Academy for one
purpose but they're also playing sports
down let's look in the future here of
can you modify their commitment can you
open it up even more than what you did
for Keenan Reynolds is it
how important is recruiting getting
maybe more of a marquee athlete there it
the reason you go to the Naval Academy
is to become a naval officer or a Marine
officer that's that's the main reason
and the only reason we've modified
people like Keenan modified their
service commitment is because they help
us recruit not athletes but just great
Midshipmen I mean Navy the Naval Academy
number one public university in America
according to US News and World Report
number two STEM science technology
engineering mathematics after a school
called MIT and these these guys and
these women but these guys that play
football for Navy go to one of the
toughest
academic institutions in the country and
they've got to they've got to meet all
those requirements they've got to meet
all their military requirements and then
they play Division one football and they
beat people like Notre Dame yeah
this year I mean that's astounding 92%
of Navy Navy athletes graduate on time
92% after their second year
everybody in navy has to make a decision
it's called the two for 7:00 dinner if
you sign up for those last two years at
the academy you're signing up for
another five and you know somebody like
Keenan Reynolds went into that signed up
know and that's that's pretty astounding
we had last year more than 20,000
applicants for about 1100 places we get
the best people and 60% 60% played
intercollegiate athletics what happened
after 9/11 with those numbers they went
up after 9/11 but they're they're the
highest they've ever been now why
because it is a tough place it's a it's
a hard academic place
it is a hard military place but we put
out the best leaders in this country and
this generation just like every
generation before wants to we got a lot
of patriots we got a lot of people
wanting to serve how did it how did it
play with Colin Kaepernick and what he
did prior to games is that a topic of
conversation that you've had with the
cadets Midshipmen but no it's not but
I'll tell you the the most of the
feedback I got it's what we fight for
it's you you got a right to speak your
mind it's the freedom of speech it's in
the Constitution and that's what you
raise your right hand and swear to
protect and defend not just everything
you agree with but everything that's in
the Constitution if your phone rings at
2:00 in the morning
what are you thinking well first I'm
worried that maybe one of my daughters
you haven't that happened to him yeah
but otherwise you know we're global yeah
we're around the globe around the clock
things are gonna happen all all 24 hours
and we're the only global Navy we're but
we're also America's are waiting we
don't ever get a home game one of the
things that happens is that people don't
see sailors and Marines much there are
no permanent homecomings for sailors and
Marines I mean the Army and the Air
Force are like firemen they go out and
fight fires they come back to the
firehouse they train to fight more fires
and you got to have them the Navy is
more like the cop on the beat our
operational schedule our tempo is the
same in war and in peace
we we're out there we're out forward
that's where the Navy and Marine Corps
belongs and we the thing that we
uniquely give the country is presence
you know being at the right place not at
the right time but all the time we're
always there and so you know something's
gonna be happening around the world you
hope it's not bad but if it's it's a
it's a 24 hour hour a day job for not
just for me but particularly for those
sailors and Marines who are who are
formed he is the US Secretary of the
Navy Ray Mabus joining us here in the
man cave last time you were on when we
talked and I know you're powerful and I
don't know if you're this powerful but I
said could we get Top Gun two movie made
and you I thought were hinting it maybe
we were going to have a Top Gun - we're
still trying you are have you been in
talks with Tom Cruise that we anytime
somebody wants to make a movie that's
got the Navy in it we're in talks with
them because we get we're gonna get
script approval if we're gonna help them
have there been talks yeah there
different talks breaking news here Top
Gun 2 has been green-lighted lit by the
secretary the name is that true now is
this part of the will greenlight it if I
can have a role in the movie is that you
didn't put that in there I really wish I
could but yeah well they have to have
and I'm and I'm gonna be gone you when
are you done I'm done when this
president's done that's it that's it
would you want to stay on you know I've
had a great run I've had like I said
when I leave Josephus Daniels or
Secretary of the Navy during World War
one had an assistant named Franklin
Roosevelt Josephus Daniels took alcohol
off Navy ships got replaced with coffee
sailors were very sarcastically say
let's go get a cup of joe which is where
that expression came from I didn't know
that and Gideon Welles Abraham Lincoln's
Secretary of the Navy that's the two
people and we'll be with and its
longest-serving Oh secretaries of the
night congratulations that's not bad
company so you're done you're ready to
go I'm done I'll never be ready to leave
this job and but it's our system and and
it's time for somebody else to come in I
also asked if we could get a boat don't
have to be a fancy boat and we even came
up with a tugboat
could we get a tugboat named after this
show is that are you open to it though
you know I'm sure open to naming things
after sports because I've named the USS
Cooperstown mm-hmm
now you named it I named look at you you
got the power I got I get to name all
Navy ships well could you do that before
you leave office like just a tugboat
like 10 minutes before you and you're
walking out the door to say hey that
tugboat is the USS Dan Patrick show you
know if I did that it would be 10
minutes whether I was wanting to walk
out the door President Obama's not gonna
care he'll be he'll he'll be fine with
that
he will okay trust me you know how many
Cubs won the World Series he's fine with
anything now for for every ship I name
yeah I get about a hundred
recommendations at least a hundred and
so it's like a former governor
Mississippi told me one time you know
when I was governor elect I'm from a
town of a thousand people and I was a
second governor from that town in thirty
two years my dad's lawyer got elected
governor when I was seven and he said
any times you got a job and ten people
want it and you pick one of them you
just made nine enemy and you got one in
grade who thinks he got it on merit all
right if you do a USS ESPN before you do
a damn Patrick show I'ma be a little
disappointed okay have you think I'll
make that promise you will there will
not be a USS ESPN before before Dan
Patrick show right by the way I did grab
big deal
they secretary brought in a helmet that
they're gonna wear tomorrow that Navy is
gonna wear tomorrow against army I
assumed it was a gift I grabbed it the
secretary said oh no no no I'm taking
that with me you brought in a helmet
just you can't tease me like that bring
it a picture next time why not because
the helmet like I keep stuff look at
this I'm a hoarder you are me too I
would like to I would like to have the
tie to wear on football night in America
I can make that day you can make that
happen I can make that happen so Sunday
night after Navy beat army I would have
faith year in a row I would of course I
would have that tie on football night in
America okay I'll make that deal cuz I
bought this tie oh so that's yours that
they help their Navy about the helmet
can i buy that helmet yes how much that
helmet cost 600 bucks 600 bucks that's a
hundred each for all of us here yeah boy
Dan the colonel behind me looked at me
and tap me on the shoulder said the
helmets coming with us he was not
smiling okay the team gave me that
helmet yesterday well they did oh so
it's your helmet it's my helmet but I
got a write a check for it I want to
make sure he writes the check here okay
oh you don't have to worry about that I
lawyers lined up they introduced a and I
what was amazing Senator McCain came in
and I gave him some Dan Patrick show
gear and he sent me a check back from
his personal account for $200 he said I
don't know how much it cost
I hope this covers it and he sent me a
check for $200 well I got to do it for
anything worth more than 20 bucks that I
get I have to pay for it okay as long as
long as I'm in this job all right I
understand it but I'll take the time
wear it on football night in America
good luck good luck in the game tomorrow
have fun oh we're gonna have fun it's
it's gonna be a great it doesn't matter
what the records are doesn't matter
anything army-navy that's special he is
the Secretary of the Navy or as he likes
to say he's the MVP of the Navy he is at
least for I don't know a couple more
weeks right a couple more yeah six weeks
yeah thank you we we appreciate it and
thanks for having a sense humor no Dan I
love you show listen to it watch it all
the time and you know the sports in the
military real close can you get can you
put our show on these battleships could
you miss submarines could you make sure
that those guys are able to have some
entertainment there you've taken away
alcohol so can you put this back I
didn't take away out I know I just want
to make no no no of course you didn't
but but no I have watched lots of games
you know own ships
you know Armed Forces Network Carrie's
college games cares pro games you know I
was in Azerbaijan and watched Ole Miss
and Arkansas in that terrible game where
Arkansas they don't miss and knocked us
out of the top four on a fourth and 25
and overtime you're not bitter though
right you've moved past it no I well you
always have Navy football and and that's
my team I mean you asked me what kind of
athlete I was you know I was a somebody
brought me a program
when I was in high school a freshman
number 89 Raymond Mabus 5:6 109
defensive end but I get to go down on
the field I get to stay on the field
with Navy I get to go in the locker room
how good is that
congrats on your success and thank you
for stopping by he's the US Secretary of
the Navy Ray Mabus the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
[Music]